hey everyone welcome back to the game
sports demo stage here at e3 2017
joining Oscar myself to talk about Ace
Combat 7 is the franchise director
connor-san and we have Mike here who's
translating welcome you guys to meet you
thank you for coming
what are you showing at this year's e3
John on you mister is Reno Manon booyah
Rita Ora Hajime distance master so for
the first time we're showing the non VR
content of Ace Combat 7 I believe we
have a live gameplay demo as well that
we can cut to and read great if you
could talk us through it there to the
rival Oman India course it's a mission a
llama meeting conjugate up you know how
Costa was welcome kikuno serrano show
again you two go and he's going to cut
up your demos so one of the biggest
points I want to direct your attention
to is sort of the expression and way
we've done the skies so I don't know
what's on Saturday nights in it so all
of the clouds that you see here on the
screen are calculated with physics oh
yeah come on on Akane hi take Tomas
condo mother country University Atari
talkative yoga mat the tools inch Dimas
so we've tried to push the boundaries
and when you go through the cloud you
can actually feel like that's sort of
like the wetness the dampness and sort
of that turbulence to what prompted the
return to the strange real universe it's
engineer no university mankato
a buddy numbering the title to go to the
user by Japan on Sunday terminology and
show two states or engineer go with the
model stuff because it is a numbered
title in the Ace Combat franchise and
legacy we wanted to go back to sort of
the roots and what the fans really
considered the true line of a scumbag
what does it allow you to do to return
the stranger that you couldn't do before
and after in lieu de mañana en esto sólo
para tanto intersect on Iran ie cocoon
he detention cry monogatari authentic
our motto is from optimal franchise in
Lake City Utah Crocker I could my story
on yoga take away two things I think it
really allows us to explore some non
real or semi sci-fi type weapons and
enemies which is not something we can do
in sort of the space of real
and really kind of expand on the story
of strange real I'm interested
Ace Combat 7 has been I mean Ace Combat
as a series has been going on so long
now it's such a much-loved franchise how
do you balance trying to appeal to
longtime fans of the franchise like
you're saying returning to strange real
that that's going to attract to them but
also how do you attract new players at
the same time general fund I've actually
found or at the branding your horse so
listen a re did you turn upon you are
critical home tonight somewhat to a kite
tic-tac-toe when one stings attraction
from you are poki Roni seven Cara middle
cons the hike tomorrow handsome so it's
kind of a two pound attack and that's
very good point that you bring up for a
lot of the existing ace combat fans you
want them to see this in fact wow this
is it this is the ace combat we've been
waiting for but it's also it feels very
revolutionary in the sense that we made
the sort of overall appeal very
approachable so in fear seeing this for
the first time it's not like you need to
have experience with all the past days
combats to be able to dive right in Don
James solo talking about commercial
Ergotelis used to hide victim like that
and I really believe that just the
visuals and the skies and people who
just want to try soaring through them
that appeal alone will be enough to get
a lot of new people the game was
originally a PlayStation 4 exclusive but
is now believe on all platforms can you
explain why it's coming to such a wider
audio session RPS Lopez Gilliam are
called hapa hero audience in Utica so a
particular Okinawa comment on us in
detail excited over all their
PlayStation 4 Xbox one pro steaming
mucho systems tada
appreciation we are well I excuse me the
keys bonus of course you wanted to share
this with as many people as possible but
I do want to remind you that the VR
experience is exclusively on the
PlayStation platform what's it been like
designing for a VR because it is such a
you know difference in Hardware
difference in how you have to design for
the design because I'm let's get all hi
when we are home Toni Egger taking a
soda tell you coming over Scylla's we
are in Costa
musashi Paris a comedy it's needed a
pilot the utica program taking on their
approach children's insolence oh it's a
completely different approach and in the
sort of non vr which we're calling a you
get a bigger focus on the campaign in
the story so there's a lot more
cinematography so you're looking at it
through a third-person perspective you
can move the camera around whereas in
the VR aspect from start to finish
you're always going to be in the
first-person perspective how is it being
developing fovea I assume that's the
first time that your Studios done it or
they're crying out the hajimeta
duty guide k can you teach a social
scene cast upon taha see me today
Palomar session is on OCD yo-yo to bring
dr. ito cotton or a comedy kudos things
so as a team you are correct is the
first time we were developing on the VR
platform and we had to take a lot of
caution and approaching it and making
sure people weren't getting any motion
sickness and that kind of thing okay
rainbow domino Santo Guillermo taught
Scotty Jason okay Kay McCulloch instance
and but I personally have had experience
developing I know if you've seen them in
the arcades a very dome-shaped kind of
arcade fighters like they star wars all
yes like stars and in doing so a lot of
that experience is kind of you could see
here and it applies in the motion
sickness aspect I gather you've been
with the series for a long time now is
franchise director it must by this point
feel just like a baby of yours right
like how does it feel knowing evil heart
on the new game having been with the
series for such a long time violation
slugged a master at acedemic I had civil
society marriage karaoke no masakeen
Yuma County knows when you join a galaxy
vatos a movie tomatillo see Sonoma tacho
Sanga night Oh see discuss in this
manner there it's our legacy doctor to
card with sad eyes a sovereign and
chosen vehicle key photo collages I'm
kind of where we are
and I think it's really a balancing act
and I feel a lot of responsibility
coming back to the main line of numbered
titles in the Ace Combat franchise that
being said I don't believe in just
recycling the same game and kind of
putting your number on in fact I think
if you do that the series is going to
die so what I really want to do with
this one is kind of challenge a new
status quo and for Ace Combat 7 that was
the VR aspect not only do you have the
VR but nowadays modern consoles are so
incredibly powerful got the ps4 Pro the
Xbox one X what differences today allow
for the game universe with the mana
movement with the game hangar -
incorrect
totally creative ass for Osito moon wha
it's my tottemo app I created since
taiko - aha don't see no poetic Masonic
okay so the economy coasting you know
obviously the evolution hardware is a
huge huge factor but and as one in the
position of creator we always feel that
boundary and no matter what we try to do
or like oh cool we have more potential
to work with but we're always going to
hit a certain wall I think that sort of
is a fun part of the development process
what's you is the heart of a scumbag
combatant Marco shinty tamashii terminal
number when you're free Torres a cake
owner with Cicero G when you only eat
America t-toku Road Odenton I really
believe it's just the sort of vastness
of being able to fly freely throughout
the sky and how well you can do it so
Toby ty kinamania no penalty can either
click on and I truly believe that flying
is one of the sort of very innate
desires I one kind of has somewhere deep
down this is the like you said the first
time the Ace Combat has gone into VR can
you ever envisage a VR only ace combat
game via hot meat sauce in Santa Coloma
we are only no gamer so so lucky Moscow
Oh
Eskimo plan franchises oh dear
giancarlo cigar tostada ma-mutt ashore
no semana she uses an automatic my a
particular number yarn on Camp Pendleton
as the Ace Combat franchise I think it's
entirely possible
having said I think the adoption rate
for the VR platform is still very young
and infantile in its state and what I've
sensed from looking at all communities
and fans that this is the sort of format
of Ace Combat people still want at the
core how is fan reaction bin do you find
that compared to say 10 15 20 years ago
you have a deeper relationship with them
honto no koto chanto be conscious so no
agenda might gravity como screaming are
you right now to control SNS table
control in choke set syndrome not small
keisuke and I understand the more you
don't know how Novak I to tailor their
heist or texting I think the sort of
distance between developers and fans
have has been closed significantly
especially with the adoption of social
media services and a lot of times I'll
get tweets or messages directly to me
from the fans with some feedback and of
course I can't address every single one
of them but it is a large part of the
development process so Sakai is your
Korakuen on my site you'll manage the
famous and because it's coming from all
over the world there are some whose
names I can't even read or pronounce
important we had I don't know what
language is did well it sounds like it's
going to be a really great entry in the
franchise but it sounds like to me at
least that you're putting the fans first
going back to strange real is that the
priority for you going forward to always
put the fans first so we can mark on the
strange again water cycle - well pumping
franchises or Keen around on my dystonia
and Alaska door sweep or phone wall
juice turn your na hoona mark when we
interviewed clients ask a person fungi
cookie bun vehicle engine omphalocele
party we cut slot I'll polish a doctor
you don't remember off the beginning
Simon okay to our families and wrinkles
found amazing bra size shoe height
Odessa console to go to write you wanted
us we think
it is my belief in development there are
many elements at play you have the
developer as publishers pipeline
distribution but at the end of the day
the people who are going to give you the
final answer and evaluation are the fans
and the community and the consumer
do you see ace combat 7 as being the
start of the new future or do you what
do you hope the legacy of the game will
be conceived mutoscope note Emma atashi
Mariah quad heiglemann Castle Tom Becca
she taken in August Atlas no segundo
silica sio2 a combat ignore a book
that's no good it's just kind of like a
starting point for us and what will come
next
thinking about that as all as our jobs
mother Jesus and I can't tell you what
that is yet Kanaka no son thank you so
much for joining us Mike thank you as
well guys make sure you don't go
anywhere we'll be right back with some
project cause to